the third fallacy i showed you was this
one which had to do with this imaginary
number business okay
and i will admit i was kind of taking a
bit of advantage of the fact that you're
not very familiar
with how these numbers work but still it
seems
to function and convince most of you and
have you very confused
so let me show you how it works most
people and by the way
i am i played a bit of a trick on you
it's a it's a
well-known principle in magic that if
you want to trick people what you do is
you draw
attention to something you make a big
deal about something which has nothing
to do with how the trick actually works
right so people get distracted they get
convinced that that's
that's what they need to concentrate on
that's what they they need to watch
carefully
you'll even hear magicians say okay now
watch very carefully as i
and that's an almost certain guarantee
that the trick is either already
finished
right so you've missed it or they're
gonna do that and then off on the side
something's happening that you're not
paying attention to
and that's where the trick really lies
okay i did the same thing here
most people thought i made a big deal
out of this part here
right and people said you know a half
equals two quarters right i established
that
and because i made such a big deal about
this right i had some people convinced
people like no maybe a half really isn't
two quarters because this seems to
this seems to lead to problems obviously
okay um or alternatively
some people thought that this was the
issue me breaking apart the indices okay
but it's very easy to see why this is
not a problem right if you go back to
your index laws
right if you have something raised to a
power and you raise the whole thing
to a power okay um our index laws tell
us this
right um m and that's that's really a
to the power of m times m but you can
see if i reverse these this is no issue
right
if i go put the n there and the m there
just interpreting this law the same way
this should be a to the power of nm
which is m times m and look
multiplication you can change its order
it's a commutative operation
okay so therefore these two things
they're equal
no problems okay so people again thought
the issue was here
okay um they thought it had to be an
issue because when you got
when i get rid of the negative right
that seems to be where
i get to show this very unconvincing
result okay
but i had you all fooled here's where
the real problem is the real problem
is in the very last line okay now i've
included this one which i didn't include
in your in the original proof just to
show you
it's not because i'm mucking around with
the definition of an index or anything
like that that's not the problem
okay it's easy to see that there's an
issue here
because the fourth root of one the
fourth root of one
okay if i give you an equation like this
right x squared is equal to one
right everyone knows because we're
familiar with quadratics
but there are two solutions to this and
they're plus or minus one
okay that's a quadratic degree of the
polynomial is two
by the same logic it ought to be
standard reason
that if it's a power of four equals one
then there shouldn't be two solutions
there should be
four solutions and there are four
solutions the four solutions are plus or
minus one
just like here right or plus or minus
the square root of negative one
okay because think about how this works
right let's go with um let's go with the
positive
square root of negative one right if i
multiply this by itself
four times okay i'm gonna have the
square root of negative one the square
root of negative one
the square root of negative one and one
last time but this is easy
right these two will become negative one
these two will become
negative one as well and then they'll
cancel and you'll get one
right you can reverse the same thing
with the negative square root of
negative one
because you'll have one two three four
negative signs that will all cancel
you'll still end up with a positive okay
so in fact the real issue
is that this statement here from that to
that they're actually equal
they are equal but i chose the wrong
solution it was just like with the trig
fallacy
before this is a valid solution to this
but it's not the right one
in this context i should have chosen
this one and that's where the fallacy
lies okay
so clear this direction watch out when
people tell you
pay close attention to this because
they're probably trying to trick you